[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday the 7th of
july i'm kate andrews spectators
economics editor and your host this week
on this week's show
boris johnson has resigned what's next
i'll speak to james forsyth and katie
balls
james writes in this week's cover piece
about the tories who want the top job
he'll be on the show to talk us through
the runners and riders with andrew neal
oil wrestling and inflation hannah
lucinda smith writes in this week's
magazine that this odd pairing
exemplifies the trouble with turkey's
economy she'll join me on the show
it was the 74th birthday of the nhs this
week should we be celebrating i'll speak
to isabel hardman
and finally do we really know what makes
us happy rory sutherland doesn't think
so he'll be on spectator tv
a spectator subscription is now better
value than ever before as a new
subscriber joining today you'll pay just
one pound a week for unlimited online
and app access in your first year to
subscribe today go to spectator dot co
dot uk forward slash tv offer
and why not subscribe to our youtube
channel click the red button at the
bottom of this video and tap the bell
icon to make sure you never miss an
episode
boris johnson has resigned as prime
minister it's been a messy few days and
a messy few hours to give us the latest
i'm joined by our political editor james
forsyth and our deputy political editor
katie balls
hi both thanks for joining me
james the prime minister has resigned
what happens now
there will now be a tory leadership
contest and we don't yet know the
timetable for that that will be settled
by the new executive of the 1922
committee on monday there are two
schools of four in the tory party about
it one set of people say look we need a
new prime minister in place soon uh it
would be best to get the parliamentary
rounds done before parliament breaks up
for the summer uh later on this month
use august for hustings around the
country and have a new leader in place
by september
other people argue
that uh look lots of candidates running
think of people like swallow brotherhood
are not well known you need to be able
to kind of kick the tars on them this is
a really big choice for the tory party
they shouldn't rush it so
why not wait until for the parliamentary
rounds until september uh and i'm better
than you leader at conference now i
think that the
problem with the latter scenario is i
just don't see how that works if boris
johnson is still prime minister it would
be an awfully long time to have him in
there doing that job uh and
so people who ministers who advocate
that solution tend to favor the idea of
dominic robb stepping in as interim
prime minister but even if dominick
roberts did step in as interim prime
minister and he has done this job before
when boris johnson was in hospital with
kobit and he did it kind of calmly and
collegiately by all accounts
i mean the challenge is that is an
awfully long time for the country not to
have a prime minister uh who is going to
be the leader who takes the country
through the next election uh when you
consider the whole variety of crises
whether it's the energy crisis or the
security crisis facing the country katie
there's already a lot of criticism of
the prime minister's resignation speech
some of his own mps suggesting that they
don't think he resigned properly and a
lot of blame that it seems the prime
minister put on everybody but himself
what did you make of his remarks
i think it was quite a classic boris
johnson speech in some ways if you
compare it to theresa may when she
resigned
and she actually at one point appeared
overcome of emotion very sad boris
johnson was bullish and effectively
boris johnson um made quite clear he
didn't want to go
he laid the blame for that squarely at
the parliamentary party he said it
become clear to him that a majority in
the parliamentary party wanted him to go
and he had reluctantly accepted this um
after having pointed out to them that it
might seem a little bit odd to have a
leadership election right now i think
he's well eccentric and then he went on
to talk about darwinism and also talk
about this idea of a herd mentality in
westminster that had meant that he had
effectively been forced out of office
now
these are all things that he clearly
feels and i think that is in keeping
with everything we've heard about how
boris jones and his hand of partygate
accusations uh questions about the chris
pinscher scandal initially at least um
but i think in terms of where you go
next it wasn't really a speech with uh
self-reflection in the sense of i've
made mistakes and i regret this
promotion not going the way i wanted it
was more other people have looked at
things in a way which means that i can
no longer stand here and he thanked his
wife carrie johnson he's like to stop at
checkers
but he did not thank any of his cabinet
not even the cabinet he remained in post
and hadn't resigned some of him such as
jack the scotland secretary who stood uh
at one side of downing street at when
when uh the prime minister was talking
um so i think for the line that was uh
the most intriguing was he said he would
support the next leader as much as he
could now that's not really a cast iron
promise that he's going to support the
next leader and i think the manner in
which this has happened the fact that
number 10 did not uh want to go along
with what cabinet ministers are pushing
for it means that you can imagine a
world where boris johnson whether you
know as a as a columnist as a speaker
even as a backbench mp has lots of
opinions on what his uh his successor
should or shouldn't be doing
yeah i think katie is right i think you
saw the beginning of the creation of the
boris johnson myth uh there which is you
know we were only a few points behind in
midterm the herd as he called them
panicked under kind of media sledging
and got rid of him and i think this is
the history boris johnson intends to
write and it will be kind to him i think
he will use his columns his speeches his
autobiography to promote it and i
thought it was i thought it was
almost kind of classic of a genre here
but there was no recognition by boris
johnson of his own role in his downfall
james can you give us some insight into
what happened over the past 18 hours or
so because yesterday evening it seemed
like the prime minister was becoming
even more bullish about his position in
staying in downing street as people were
resigning around him he was firing his
leveling up secretary michael gove and
then we get to this morning and he comes
out and he resigns uh what changed in
that very short period of time
well it is a short period of time
because you talked to cameron and mrs
you spoke to him very very late last
night and boris johnson was still full
of i've got my mandate uh and and with
no intention to go anywhere i think
ultimately what has led to him resigning
is it was becoming quite clear by this
morning that he would not be able to
staff the government
and if you don't have ministers if you
if you don't have you can't govern
without a government um and i thought
you could see this but by kind of 7 30
this morning i think four ministers had
extra more ministers have resided i mean
the scoring rate of ministerial
resignations is faster than the england
cricket team's approach under under
brendan mccollum
and i think i think it was clear at that
point but you know you couldn't have a
government and people were resigning
from the kind of jobs that you can't
leave vacant you can't leave a job as
security minister vacant you can't leave
a job of northern ireland secretary
vacant and so i mean that is ultimately
what forced him to go
katie boris johnson is often referred to
as a marmite figure you you really love
him or you really hate him and he even
alluded to that in his speech when he
said some of you will be happy about
this i know others will be disappointed
will that be a calculation now within
the tory party that he has been ousted
by his own mps by his own cabinet by
vast resignations are they going to be
at all worried about any grassroots
members that actually feel like boris
has been a bit hard done by
well i think you'll still see despite
the disruption in chaos of the past 48
hours
those in the leadership contest he'll be
talking about uh you know a loyalty to
boris johnson and praising him and for
example you had liz trust the foreign
secretary who had kept pretty quiet
obviously said she was going to continue
to back boris johnson i think it helped
that she was at the g20 when a lot of
the you know the peak madness was
kicking off um the cabinet minister is
going to see the prime minister um but
today after he made the decision saying
uh boris johnson has made the right
decision but then quickly praising all
these things in his premiership i think
ben wallace adopting a similar approach
so i think we're going to have loyalist
candidates who will be trying to keep
that that group on side who didn't
necessarily want boris johnson to go i
do think though he looked at the polling
um after rishi sunik and sajid javed
both resigned one of the things that was
quite striking was the number of
conservative voters who turned against
boris johnson so i don't think this is a
situation where um mps at present worry
that there's going to be a huge backlash
to this i think they think it's dragged
out for such a long time this is uh
something which uh
figures in the grassroots and voters
will sympathize with them on of course
this depends a lot on does the
government now get its act together what
does the future leader do um if the
situation is worse than what we just had
then people could of course change their
mind
james and katie thanks for joining me
so if not boris then who james also
writes this week's cover piece about the
contenders the tory mps who want to take
that top job from boris johnson he
joined me yesterday to speak about the
leadership hopefuls as did the
spectator's chairman and the host of the
andre neil show andrew neal
james in your cover piece this week you
asked what and who is next for the
conservative party as the latest scandal
may prove fatal for boris johnson who
are the likely candidates
well tourist races are always more like
the grand national than the derby
they're unpredictable the favorite often
doesn't win but even by those standards
this is an exceptionally open field one
of the reasons that boris johnson has
survived for as long as he has is that
there hasn't been an obvious successor
who commands the kind of
support of the bulk of the parliamentary
party i think when the contest at the
moment the kind of conservative home
survey which has a pretty good record
unto a leadership contest suggests that
ben wallace the defense secretary is
currently the favorite but i think very
tellingly he's the favorite on only 16
of the vote which is a remarkably low
share to be leading the field on i think
what that tells you is that this is this
is a very open race where the policy
prospectus is that the candidates set
out are going to matter a lot and where
their performance is in the hustings and
the debates
and crucially
what the polls say about their
electability are going to be crucial
we'll come back to the defense secretary
who's leading that con home poll but
first andrew one of the big things
spoken about during the multitude of
scandals the government has faced in
recent months is that absence of a
viable alternative what do you think of
the tory options is there a well of
talent in the tory party right now
well it's certainly true that the
absence of a clear alternative or a
clear favorite has helped to keep mr
johnson in par
but even that is now beginning to run
out of steam and increasingly i think
the view is that uh who would be better
to replace him or almost anybody so i
think that's why we're heading towards a
leadership contest that uh
he could be gone in hours he could be
gone in days i think he'll certainly be
gone in weeks he may not even make the
summer recess
now
if
if you want
a rundown of the runners and riders
as to who's likely to be the next story
leader there's nothing better than
james's article in
the upcoming edition of the spectator he
gets all the
the right names and all the right
comments on who they are there is no
clear favorite which will make this a
fascinating race and it will be even
more fascinating because it will have a
dynamic
that those who start off well
uh will could well flander and those who
don't get a good start may certainly be
coming through the last hurdle so i
think it's absolutely wide open
this is not a stellar
tory
lineup
compared to years gone by it's not
particularly special but there's a fair
amount of variety there
gender variety ethnic variety left and
right variety there is certainly choice
and the tories are meant to believe in
choice and they will have a choice and i
think the race itself will test the
metal of those who i think they can be
the party leader it's certainly
going to keep us busy and be worth a
watch
well i certainly concur the viewers
should be reading james's cover piece
this week it covers all the bases
james i want to pick up on andrew's
point that at this point it seems like
almost any leader might be better than
boris johnson this calculation has
changed quite quickly for some mps
hasn't it because it was just weeks ago
around that first no-confidence vote for
boris johnson uh that some mps who
weren't very pleased with the prime
minister's record were more worried
about another candidate who they really
didn't like managing to make it to the
final two and get voted into the party
leadership spot by the grassroots but
now it seems with these resignations
especially from the more junior law of
the tory party on mass they're just
saying enough is enough and we're
willing to take our chances wherever a
leadership contest may go
yeah it's remarkable who is resigning
look at the fact that alex burkhart who
was until very recently boris johnson's
uh parliamentary private secretary has
just resigned as as a minister
i mean there are two things have
triggered this shift one is the tiverton
and wakefield by-elections showed that
boris johnson now motivates the
anti-tory vote more than the tory vote
and he is one of the big drivers of the
tactical voting that so threatens the
tory party right now
the second is the chris pincher business
because after party gate number 10
kept telling tory mps we professionalize
the operation you won't have these kind
of self-inflicted wounds again and
you've now had possibly the deepest
self-inflicted wound of all and i think
toriyama's have just come and from you
know the ministers who've resigned and
told ribs i've just come to the
conclusion that you know this isn't
going to stop as long as boris johnson
is in number 10 and so it is better to
get this done i think one of the other
things that is driving the speed
is a sense among uh tory
parliamentarians that if they're going
to have to have a leadership contest it
would be better to do it over the summer
it would look less self-indulgent over
the summer and to do it this autumn when
the cost of living crisis is really
biting and people would say why on earth
are you doing that rather than getting
on with governor in the country andrew
what did you make of sacha javid and
rishi sinak's resignations do you think
this is the start of their leadership
bids
oh yes it's the start of their
leadership bids and it's also the start
of leadership bids of those who have not
yet resigned i mean they're all getting
their ducks in a row and they're right
too i mean there is going to be a
leadership contest now i mean no doubt
about that the prime minister is dying
of death by a thousand cuts and it is
only a matter of time and as each day
goes by even each hour goes by it looks
like it will be sooner rather than later
so
it's only natural in the state of
politics that they should begin to get
their campaigns going uh put out
soundings what support they can count on
what positions should they take who
would their main rivals be all that
there's nothing ignoble or underhand
about that that's all part of
the stuff of normal politics and i do
think it will be important for the i
mean the conservatives are slow learners
but and so it's taken them a while
to understand that if they stick with
boris johnson their toast is finished
it's over he'll never get better he is
what he is he can't change he even
admitted that to the bbc on the today
program a couple of weeks ago you know
there's a whole
industry out there that has willed him
to get better
and he never does he can't help himself
i've willed him to get better in various
formats and it's never happened so i
think they realize they need to make a
change the sooner the better and i think
also as james was saying
given the state of the country
the sooner it is done the better and the
sooner they make up their minds who they
want as their new leader will be the new
prime minister the better as well
because there's so
much to do i mean whoever
gets into dining street after this
we'll find
chaos i mean it will be a mess
uh nothing will work no buttons pushed
will reply it will be like there had
been a non-stop party and nobody cleaned
up afterwards so the sooner someone gets
in to sort this out it's a herculean
task i wouldn't wish it on anybody
certainly not my best friend
but it needs to be done
but they will find some gold wallpaper
um andrew ben wallace was mentioned at
the start of our chat today you
interviewed him for spectator tv for our
christmas episode last year what do you
make of him
ben wallace is a good chap he's a
traditional tori he sounds a traditional
tory he looks a traditional tour he's an
army man he's had a good war in the
sense that he
has been an excellent secretary of state
defense uh in the build-up too
and in the invasion of ukraine
by russia he's been one of the important
voices inside nato uh inside the
alliance the americans regard him highly
as well
he is the kind of person that the tories
used to feel most comfortable with
i think as james makes very strongly in
his uh piece in this week's spectator he
is a bit of a one-note song
we know how good he is on defense we
know that the services the armed
services and the ministry of defense
like them they regard him they think he
they've got what the french would call
an olm syria in charge unlike no names
no pack drill a few of the people that
have occupied that position uh recently
so but but we as james points out we
don't know what his economic policies
would be we don't know what his social
attitudes are all of that will have to
come out and it look we don't even know
if he wants it there was a lot of talk
that he actually he may prefer to be the
next head of nato which of course he
would be ideally qualified to do and
it's about time we had to pray again in
that job and it may be that the hustings
are not to his making i would say
there's one thing though
that he would be a good man for the
union
and by that i mean the united kingdom
he's a scot anglicized scott sounds
english
but he's got a name called wallace which
is also the name of the most famous
scottish patriot in a thousand years of
history he cares about the union he
knows about scotland he was a member of
the
a member of the scottish parliament and
whereas wise tories have always known
that as long as boris johnson was prime
minister they could never
never risk another referendum even if
one was forced on them uh with ben
wallace's prime minister
that risk is kind of gone uh he would be
an asset uh in a referendum on scottish
independence not a liability like the
current prime minister
james ben wallace may be leading the
conservative home pole but the betting
markets say differently at the moment at
this time of recording petty mordent and
rishi sunak are level with each other as
the top choice and you can follow those
odds on the spectators data tracker over
on our website now when it comes to the
culture wars rishi sunak has been pretty
quiet but penny mordant has been more
vocal and she is definitely on the
socially liberal side of the party how
do you think that will go down if she
were to say make it to the final two and
the vote were to be taken to the
grassroots i
struggle to see
how you could win a tour leadership
election
uh unless she shifts from her position
that trans men and men and trans women
are women because that is not a view
widely shared in the tory party and i
think it i think it puts her at odds
with most tory mps and most members now
she is very popular with younger
activists i mean the biggest biggest
challenge for penny morden is to be
certain of making the final two you need
120 mps to back her and i i struggle to
see who these 120 mps are and i think
some people will also say
well look you know you've made this
whole thing of distancing yourself from
boris johnson but you know as of
wednesday afternoon you're still in the
government you know why did you not
resign if you if you if you you know
rather than this enigmatic position over
what you did in the no confidence vote
and the like and so i think this is that
that is the challenge for her which is
you know running from inside government
but outside the cabinet is a difficult
act to pull off
james is there enough time for a new
leader to turn things around before
another election
i think there is in that if you look at
the polling labor have not established
the kind of lead uh that that would be
the that you that would be irreversible
i i also think that uh
i think that i think boris johnson has
so dominated politics but in the same
way that when the tories removed
margaret thatcher
even though john major had been her
chancellor when
and previously about her foreign
secretary
him being prime minister felt like a new
government i mean because boris so
dominates politics whoever succeeds him
whether they're in the cabinet now or
not it will feel like a new government
to people
and i think that is that does give the
tories an opportunity now the new prime
minister will be up against some some
quite significant economic headwinds but
i think the public also do get but these
are tough times that there is there is
there is no country in the western world
but that that faces
enticing economic prospects over the
next six months to two years
and i also think that they
autumn 2024 is still quite really quite
a long way off there is you know you
know
in australian politics they would tell
you that you were changing neither far
too early um and so i think there is a
chance for the tories to turn it around
i think it would it will have to be a uh
it will take skill and it will also have
to involve running in 2024 on here's
what we've done let us finish the job um
but i think it is possible
i think the other factor in play here
which is not in
boris johnson's favor kate is that
unlike
1995 when we were two way two years away
from the next election as we are now
uh the tory party had pretty much
concluded
that even getting rid of john major who
was then the prime minister wouldn't
make any difference that they were just
cruising for a brutal that tony blair
was unstoppable and he would be the next
prime minister so uh major had helped to
create this situation so just let him uh
guide the marie celeste to inevitable
tory mps don't think that yet partly
because they're not up against tony
blair um they're up against kyo starmer
tory mps not all of them but a majority
think that they can turn this around
with a new leader that if they get a new
leader in now it will seem as james says
like such a change of government and
getting some competence and direction
and strategy and policy at the heart of
government again it can be done not a
slam dunk but it can be done all is not
lost if they change leaders uh but they
need to move they need to move this
summer they need to start the fight back
the build back this autumn uh to do so
but i think that also
adds to the reasons why there is a
growing in my view now an unstoppable
unstoppable momentum to replace the
prime minister
andrew and james thanks for joining me
journalist and author hannah lucinda
smith writes in this week's magazine
about the bizarre link between oil
wrestling and inflation turkey's economy
is quickly spiraling out of control
putting a 600 year old tradition under
threat to explain hannah joins me now
hannah you write in this week's magazine
about the connection between inflation
and oil wrestling in turkey
tell us how they overlap
sure well um for anyone who doesn't know
oil wrestling is
uh certainly turkey's oldest sport and
turks claim it's actually the world's
oldest uh continual competitive sport
it's uh as the name might suggest what
happens is you have two wrestlers they
oil themselves up there they're naked
apart from a pair of buffalo leather
shorts
they oil themselves up either using uh
olive oil in the case of the festival i
was at earlier this month or more
commonly corn oil or sunflower oil
uh and then they they grapple um to
to produce very straightforward grass
yeah um it's it's an amazing thing to
watch um but it's been going for this
was the 661st
uh annual competition
in a place called copenhagen which is uh
in durham
right near the bulgarian
and greek borders so west and western
turkey
um
and
yeah um so
obviously in this festival they use
olive oil
um
it's something that's locally produced
in turkey
but
like
almost everything on the supermarket
shelves it's like its price has just
soared over the past year olive oil in
the supermarkets has doubled in price
over the last year and and other
products have gone even higher
um
so yeah so i thought this was a kind of
uh interesting way they use about three
tons of olive oil over the course of
this three-day competition so not a
cheap business yeah you see them yeah
they're literally sort of they've got a
big vat of it and they're sort of
slapping it onto themselves before they
start
wrestling and i have to under the sun as
well this is the thing that always sort
of um worries me as a fair-skinned
person when i watch this
you think god
after son you must have to put on after
that as well but oh seriously yeah
yeah
so i mean this is a really fun way to
dive into a very serious issue uh in
turkey at the moment inflation is
running above 78
why is it so high in turkey
so there's a number of reasons so
first of all there are the reasons why
we're seeing inflation everywhere so the
kind of the
aftershocks of the pandemic um the war
in ukraine also
um but
specifically to turkey there are
problems which come down to the policies
of president erdogan who's got a really
unorthodox economic theory
which is that high interest rates cause
high inflation now you talk to almost
every other economist in the world or
politician in the world and they'll say
exactly the opposite if you want to
bring inflation down you've got to put
your your interest rates up now erdogan
has been repeatedly overruling the
technocrats at the central bank who've
been trying to say that and do that he's
sacked four of those in the past few
years he's basically taken control of
monetary policy
personally in turkey and applied this
really really unorthodox theory to it um
now
what's happened there is not only is
inflation risen but also the value of
the lira has dropped um just to put it
anecdotally i moved to turkey uh nearly
10 years ago in in february 2013. at
that time it was exactly three lira to
the pound
today we're approaching 21 lira to the
pound
that's the extent to which the lira has
fallen in value
um now you know erdogan and his team
would say well there are advantages in
that we're looking for a kind of you
know high
export economy cheap labor you know this
is how we can be successful but you know
the fact is
it doesn't work because turkey imports
almost all of its energy
and obviously energy is used in
everything you know so something like
olive oil which is locally produced okay
you might have cheap wages you might
have
all kind of cheap costs at the ticket
share but you still got to transport
that olive oil to the supermarket you've
still got to have you know fuel for your
tractors
so it's it's affecting absolutely
everything not only household bills but
also you know petrol pumps uh a year ago
was about seven lira now it's about 30
lira um it's affecting absolutely
everything so you know although
erdogan likes to blame you know
the kind of factors that you know
everywhere blames now for inflation he
also likes to blame what he calls the
interest rate lobby which is
you know in his mind some kind of
shadowy international
lobby that's trying to kind of destroy
turkey but you know ultimately
it's his policies that are that's
leading to this in turkey
it's not just the oil wrestlers who are
struggling with inflated prices in your
piece you talk about how this is
affecting ordinary turks too can you
share a few of those stories
yeah sure i mean to be honest these days
you know almost every conversation
in turkey just comes round to the prices
in the shops and in fact you know i i
went out last night with a friend
and um
we started talking about art and music
and other things and after about five
minutes i was i felt you know this is
really subversive this is so odd having
a conversation which isn't about
politics at all because that's the
extent to which it dominates the
conversation in life here every time
we're going to the supermarket these
days prices have risen again
um you know nobody can keep up with it
there's been two hikes already this year
in the minimum wage it was doubled in
january it was i think 40 again just
this month state salaries also been
hiked twice private companies giving
massive pay increases a friend of mine
who works for bosch here his uh i think
his pay increase at the beginning of the
year was about 70 he's just had another
40 one
so you know everything is just trying to
keep up with these prices um but nothing
is managing it now
you know clearly
there are still people who are in a
privileged position let's say
um you know anyone who's got um an
income in foreign currency anyone who's
got savings in foreign currency
you know insulated to some extent not
entirely but instead to some extent but
even then you know the middle classes
you know um
people turks who probably might have
gone on
probably three or four domestic holidays
each year might have gone to the coast
in summer and then you know gone skiing
in winter
now we're having to sort of cut most of
that out but for the very poorest people
you know anecdotally i'm hearing about
people who
just don't buy meat anymore families who
don't buy meat anymore
that's how bad it's got
and i think the people that it's really
affecting are the urban poor you know
turkey still has a very kind of
traditional um
rural society so if you're living out in
the village somewhere you will have very
very you strong family ties you'll have
your piece of land you'll have ways to
kind of cushion the blow but if you're
poor and living in the city and you're
having to deal with not only price rises
in the supermarket
increasing the price of public transport
um also increases in you know rent rents
are shooting up unbelievably you know
again anecdotally in my neighborhood i'm
hearing about landlords um you know
kicking their tenants out tenants who
are paying five thousand lira a month so
they can get new tenants in at twenty
thousand mirror a month
um yeah it's become like that so
yeah
for the middle classes it's
it's definitely a kind of reduction in
circumstances for the poor
it's devastating um having said that
then there is another class of of people
in turkey um there is still an ultra
rich they're generally people who
have become rich through their ties to
erdogan and his party over the past 20
years
um getting state contracts things like
that
um
and
they're doing pretty well um you know
the interesting thing is if you go on
some of the toll roads in turkey these
days which are too expensive to know for
normal people to use you'll see no end
of kind of luxury sports cars using them
you'll see you know at the very top you
know erdogan and his family still
you know enjoying a very nice lifestyle
he completed his last his latest summer
palace just a few years ago so you know
there is this kind of
growing
gulf between the people at the very top
and everyone else
so how long until that golf and the
policies of erdogan backfire on his
government
well i mean i think most people would
say they have backfired already but the
question is how long until they backfire
in a way that affects him
now nine years ago in 2013
there were huge mass protests against um
erdogan's government they they didn't
start because of the economy they
started because of environmental issues
but they really swelled into a kind of
mass
protest movement and the interesting
thing is now you know
in almost every way the the situation
that turks are in is so much worse but
nobody can imagine these kind of mass
protests taking place because there has
been such a clampdown
on democratic freedoms so
many of those people who took kind of
really active roles in those protests
nine years ago are now in prison often
serving full life sentences
more have left the country
others are sort of you know subdued into
silence
um there's a new generation of turks now
you know turks who are now in their
early 20s who've never had any
experience of you know being able to go
to the streets and and protest or any
experience of having a free media or
anything like that
um so you know the idea that
this will end in
kind of you know
mass protest mass civil unrest i think
is fairly unlikely
but at some point um
before next june before june 2023 turkey
is going to have elections it has to
constitutionally it's going to be the
end of the current five-year term both
for the parliament and for the
presidency
and
the polls are showing that erdogan is
let's say not popular he's he's poultry
at the lowest they've been
in 20 years he's been in power um
they're showing other potential
opposition candidates far ahead of him
showing his party i mean certainly not
on its own being able to take a
majority in the parliament perhaps not
even with its coalition partners
um
so
then the question is
how is the election going to unfold
is erdogan
and his party going to allow a kind of
free and fair election you know people
looking at
the past 10 years of elections and
taking have reasons to be cynical about
that
on the other hand you know turkey isn't
a country like russia or syria where
leaders can just you know completely
fake election results so you know they
can
be fine-tuned fiddle do a few things
but to you know openly you know faker
vote would be very very difficult
so then the question is you know if the
opposition
does win
then what happens
does erdogan willingly step aside what
happens to him then
uh you know what kind of um
you know justice and reconciliation can
there be in turkey you know so much has
happened over the past
ten years not just technically but then
on top of that there's the economic
problem as well whoever comes into power
next
inherits
huge economic problems
um you know and clearly you know if if
erdogan comes into power will he reverse
course in his economic policy i think
that's unlikely you know he's he's shown
himself so wedded to it
um
but if you know if the opposition comes
into power yes absolutely they're going
to reverse that that policy but
then
there's just a huge huge mess left there
to clear up you know central bank
reserves are
is scraping the floor
um
you've got
rising unemployment you've got a lot of
a huge brain drain you know a lot of
young people who
graduate with good degrees just don't
see any hope for getting a kind of
well-paid job in turkey so they've left
the country how are you going to turn
those people back so
you know
even if
um you know these coming elections
signal the end of the erdogan era i
think turkey's got a kind of really
difficult period coming up
hannah thanks for joining spectator tv
remember if you enjoy what we do at the
spectator you can subscribe to the
magazine and to our online content to
subscribe today go to
forward spectator.co.ukforwardslash tv
offer
the national health service turned 74
this week in recent years the health
service has received billions upon
billions of extra funding from the
taxpayer but public satisfaction with
the health service is at its lowest in
20 years what's going on i'm joined now
by our assistant editor isabel hardman
isabel thanks for joining spectator tv
so this week marks the 74th birthday of
the national health service but
celebrations seem somewhat muted this
year can you give us a sense of what's
going on in the nhs at the moment
well i think things are pretty pretty
miserable in the nhs at the moment which
is why you didn't see that much
celebrating in fact i i spent quite a
lot of uh
tuesday talking to nhs figures and uh it
was only sort of halfway through the the
calls and the meetings that we suddenly
remembered oh yes it's the birthday and
so that that's sort of that mentally
where they are that there's the backlog
um which uh
if you talk to people working within the
health service they'll say that they're
doing their very best to
tackle as quickly as they can and they
thought they were doing okay but the
latest wave of covid
is again really affecting them
and is slowing progress because of staff
absences and so on um
there's also
these efficiency savings that the nhs is
being expected to make it's supposed to
double its efficiency rate to 2.2 which
is a huge ask of the health service uh
in in any circumstances but with
inflation
there's a lot of worries
that that's going to be a real squeeze
in terms of how much everything costs
and that's something that amanda
pritchard who is the chief executive of
nhs england has already been laying down
markers um she gave a speech to the nhs
confederation last week where she said
that you know budgets can only stretch
so far and you can see the nhs saying
either it can't meet those targets which
pritchard at the moment is saying it can
um
or just trying to to push back against
any suggestion for from ministers
and obviously currently i believe steve
barkley is still the health secretary
he's very into efficiencies um that they
might try to squeeze things further
well i was going to say it's difficult
to talk about what the government thinks
when it comes to the nhs seeing as the
government is currently collapsing all
around us
but ministers previous to this current
upset in westminster and whoever forms
um
the next government going forward do you
think they're waking up to the realities
facing the nhs
uh
yes and no um
so i i think um
that the treasury
is not um and the reason i say that is
that um it had blocked uh very
forcefully any attempts to do proper
workforce planning and which would
in the long term
help the nhs to be more efficient
because it is hugely inefficient if you
have massive gaps on your rotors
if you have
so many vacancies within the health
service if you
cannot actually perform
the operations that you need to because
you just don't have the nurses you don't
have the doctors
and so on and uh
and this is this is a sort of ongoing
problem um in terms of the uh the other
aspect of reality which is i think a
point that you make um
a fair bit cake which is about the
actual sustainability of the nhs as it
is i mean politically that is really
really difficult and recently there was
a paper that tony blair published and
that argued that the current model is
not sustainable and i have to say having
uh just finished writing a history of
the nhs for its 75th birthday and i've
heard that phrase so many times i think
it starts to appear from the sort of
late 1960s onwards that the bevan and
beveridge model
no longer works in today's society and
the problem is is that the solutions to
that um there are the um sort of outlier
solutions uh of scrapping it and going
for something completely different
insurance-based model um which is not
only in america but in other countries
in europe and does work uh well for uh
people in in europe so we you know it's
always worth pointing out that it's not
uh the uk or america and those are the
only two models in the whole world we do
have a slightly bigger world than that
um
or changing um some of the structures
within the health service and this is
the the point that tony blair has been
making that he wants to
basically collapse the central control
over the health service and give and
integrated care boards which are
responsible for the commissioning and
provision of nhs services uh control
over pretty much everything um
that's just not going to work with the
dna of the nhs which you know was set up
to be a highly centralized highly
controlled system that was one of
bevan's objectives in nationalizing the
hospitals
it was one of the things that he said
himself that he would be the chief
receiver of complaints and ever since
then whether health secretaries have
legally been responsible for this or
legally
distanced from that they have always
ended up talking about the bedpans that
have been dropped in hospitals hundreds
of miles away they have always ended up
forcing out chief executives who aren't
performing whether or not that's their
legal duty i mean
there's a quote by alan johnson for
instance um about mid-staffs where
he had civil servants buzzing around him
saying oh you can't do this you can't do
that and he just turned around and said
piss off i'm dealing with this um and
that's that you know that's ultimately
what it comes down to is the public
expect ministers to answer questions on
everything when it comes to the health
service and i don't quite see how that's
going to change
the the spectator data hub is keeping
track of public satisfaction with the
nhs and at the moment there are actually
more people who say they're quite or
very dissatisfied with its performance
compared to those who are satisfied but
what should we read into those quite
headline statistics
yeah so there's lots of interesting
dynamics there one is the political
dynamic of who do the public blame and
they tend to blame the politicians who
they think are um
are underfunding not supporting the
health service uh properly there's also
the um the thing that um particularly
the later labour years the politicians
then really picked up which was the but
we're lucky dynamics so
you get people saying oh the nhs is in a
terrible state but we're lucky with our
local hospital and sort of still
bought into it at a local level which
can be um
hugely frustrating and disruptive
for anyone trying to embark on sensible
reforms because actually sometimes
people aren't lucky with their local
hospital and it would make more sense to
close you know the accident and
emergency into centralized services but
you never get a hospital closure that
the local politician or indeed the local
sort of vocal population are are going
to support and say you end up with
services remaining
even when it's not particularly
economical to do so
isabel in your upcoming book you
demonstrate how the nhs has been a
battleground for some of the fiercest
political contests of our time
as we look forward to an election
possibly in 2024 maybe sooner or indeed
a leadership election just within the
conservative party how is the nhs going
to figure
i think it will figure very highly uh
because
you are already getting headlines about
the number of people who are dying while
on
nhs waiting lists
you're seeing this really interesting
phenomenon
of people crowdfunding for private
medical treatment so um private medical
insurance has gone up and down depending
on who's in government the state of the
nhs but actually people who are paying
upfront rather than taking out insurance
for an operation that they need
but have been told they have a year to
wait for and in that time they worry
that they're going to get sicker or that
their quality of life is going to
plummet they just can't wait in pain for
that long so they're going onto these
gofundme sites and so on to try to cover
their their private health care um
themselves and
so
when i talk to people in the health
service and when i talk to switched on
politicians about this they see the nhs
as being in
it's probably its greatest existential
crisis since its foundation even greater
than um at the the turn of the century
in 2000 when uh people like alan milburn
tony blair were genuinely worried the
public support for the nhs was going to
was just going to disappear public
consent was was going to disappoint
you'd get middle classes um opting out
and the consent of the middle classes
was was really important at the time of
the foundation of the health service um
and so we're back in that place again
now you're gonna have a lot of people
getting very upset um in you know
hustings uh in election question times
and so on about their mother who has
been you know left to die by four
cancelled operations which was one of
the things the mavis skeet case that
prompted a big revolution in the health
service back in 2000
and that said
it isn't necessarily the case that the
nhs
always wins elections four parties and
that's the risk for labour is that they
could end up talking about the nhs uh
while not actually uh reassuring the
public or on anything else uh you look
at the 1992 election where the nhs
was a key part of labour's campaign
didn't win them that election so
so in terms of a political battleground
um
for actually winning an election i think
there's a there's a caveat there but it
will feature really heavily in the in
the campaign one last question for you
is about on the politics of this uh over
the past five or six years when it comes
to election time and there have been
quite a few what politicians promise
isn't reform it's more money um and this
has really increased uh the the funding
of the nhs uh to the point where it is
now well above the oecd
average it's increasingly difficult to
say that the nhs is underfunded do you
think politicians are going to have to
start offering something else or do you
think the public may still buy into this
idea that if we just give it a bit more
money and i'm thinking of the new
national insurance levy of course that
workers are paying now for the nhs
ketchup and the rest of it you know
do people still think that the answer is
more money or are they expecting to hear
something different from their
politicians
i think the way in which the public
reacts to attempts to reform social care
is quite instructive in this in that
they
expect things to continue to be free
even though social care isn't free for
them at the moment and um
uh
they get very upset at the idea that
they might have to um
expect a sort of lower level of service
even though the level of service and
social care is appalling as well so
um i
uh do not think that being honest with
the public about the health service
uh tends to benefit politicians and you
know we saw that in the 2017 snap
election with social care where theresa
may basically tried to uh yeah i
interviewed her about this for the book
and uh she said that the basic problem
was that they tried to be honest with
the electorate and um that it was not
something the electorate appreciated um
they don't like actually being told
about the the state of um the state of
things and how much uh it is either
going to cost or how much a health
service is going to have to change and
uh
for good or bad and you know you've
written about this kate about the the
problem with the sort of british
emotional attachment to the nhs
um brits don't want to see a change to
the model and um
they don't want to see their local
hospital killed even when as many
politicians have said to me that local
hospital is literally killing people
they will still present petitions saying
don't close this hospital um
and so
you know good luck to anyone who wants
to be honest um about the about the
alternative options but i suspect that
uh that they won't get thanked for it
but just
another example from history um kate
used to work for the iea institute of
economic affairs and they got very upset
uh
with enoch powell for saying that there
was no point in um in arguing against
the national health service as it was
because it was something that the public
wanted they wrote to him saying see how
you have comforted our enemy
i think you know if enoch powell had
sort of cottoned onto that then i
suspect that a lot of conservative
politicians today are probably going to
draw back and think no
isabel thanks for joining spectator tv
and finally do we really know what makes
us happy rory sutherland our wikiman
columnist writes in this week's magazine
that if we were all just a little more
spontaneous our lives would be better
for it to explain rory joins me now
rory thanks for joining me on spectator
tv so you write in this week's magazine
that people don't really know what makes
them happy can you explain
well it's something called effective
forecasting and it means that
essentially and this is probably for
evolutionary reasons
we're not very good at imagining or
predicting
the effect that certain life changes
will have on our enduring happiness and
in fact there's evidence that at the two
extremes someone who enjoys a lottery
win or someone who enjoys who is victim
of say a crippling illness or
bereavement
mostly after a surprisingly short time
obviously it varies their happiness kind
of returns to a baseline level
and so
our ability to predict for example we
possibly imagine that holidays will make
us happier than they really do
that would be one example where we
probably imagine that moving to a larger
house will have a longer-term effect on
our happiness well-being and enjoyment
that it really does in reality
and i think it's important because if
we're not very good at deciding in
advance what we'll enjoy
to some extent it suggests we should
leave some room for randomness
or experimentation
uh in what we do that too much planning
um is a problem in a world where we
don't really plan for happiness very
well
so is the problem not that a holiday
won't make you happy or potentially
moving to a new home won't make you
happy but that people are just too rigid
about the whole process that they
perhaps over plan
yeah i think i think that's true and of
course
i mean there's a fundamental problem
with tourism in that if you have let's
say
300 million chinese newly members of the
middle class who can probably get two
weeks vacation
and that means that once in their
lifetime they're going to go to london
and they're going to go to paris and
they're going to see the mona lisa and
they're going to see the acts of
parliament and you know and they all
visit the same tourist sites okay
because that's what they believe they
have to do in advance then there's a
fundamental problem with world tourism
and travel which is just over
concentration
and i would argue that a lot of the
things that are really charming and
enjoyable in life the things we really
like aren't necessarily the things we
assume will like
and i give the example in my article
that i much prefer chicago to new york
now if you'd asked me which is the most
exciting city in the united states i
would probably have answered i suppose
possibly las vegas possibly new york
possibly los angeles but i happened to
go on a business trip to chicago and
thought it was magical you know
architecturally it craps on uh most of
the other american cities for example
and those are the kind of things which
using advanced information you won't get
right you know
some of the nicest places i've ever been
are french towns that nobody's ever
heard of
and therefore using what we know
or what we think is important in advance
to actually plan out our lives might
actually be a mistake
can i ask rory when were you in chicago
because between november and april i
would say that is not a pleasant
experience it's actually very cold
i was first there in november bizarrely
but during kind of it during a kind of
indian summer all right actually
early november in chicago people were
swimming in the lake that was a very
warm november that's probably unusual
now i buy the fact that chicago is
climatically dependent
the only point i'd make i think is that
um if you if you're obsessed with
enjoying the things you've decided will
give you pleasure in advance you do pay
a price now in artificial intelligence
and funnily enough in the study of
animal foraging there's a name for this
and it's called the explore exploits
trade-off
there's a trade-off between exploiting
what you already know or think is
valuable
and exploring what you don't yet know
and it's possible that in a world where
we can plan our holidays down to
um absolutely
infinitesimally small details using the
internet
that we're all guilty of over planning
and the way we should go on holiday is
to say i'm going to fly into city a i'm
going to fly out of city b two weeks
later and
a large part of what happens in between
i'm going to leave down to happenstance
but rory that will intimidate a lot of
people especially
by the way it intimidates me
i mean i actually find myself having to
actually restrain my urge to plan
are there any tools out there that might
enable somebody to essentially plan to
be more spontaneous
well there is a famous idea called dice
man which is a whole concept where you
actually throw a dice to determine what
you do next or die technically i know
it's called um but um
it it is interesting one of the things
you could do is simply
uh you know plan no more than two days
ahead in a 10-day holiday for example
and i think what we do is we have an
advanced idea of perfection which we
attempt to recreate in planning our
holiday and actually when i look all i'm
saying is i look back on sort of 30
years holiday experience
and
some of the places that i've been most
delighted to have discovered
are places which i never would have
planned to visit in advance you know
they either came as a result of business
trips i went to i went to iceland which
is astounding i never would have paid to
go i'll be absolutely honest i had a
three-day business trip in iceland and
it's extraordinary you get on a plane
and three and a half hours later you
effectively land on the moon
um israel was another place i absolutely
loved without necessarily expecting it
and so a degree of um
there are two things which i think
bedevil us one of which is planning
according to what we know and fantasize
about not what happens to be out there
and the other one i think is just social
pressure i think a large part of holiday
making is actually you know bragging to
other people
um and i think the
the urge to
go somewhere which will sound cool to
other people
uh might be
profoundly limiting in fact in terms of
how much we enjoy things
well i'll keep that in mind when i
bookmark my next holiday rory i might
even bring some dice i i mean by the way
by the way i don't i don't necessarily
recommend this for every single holiday
you take
but i think i think having a certain
number of vacations which are much more
random and i agree it does take a
certain amount of courage you know even
in a uk holiday just setting off in a
car without knowing where you're going
to stay that night
um particularly in an age of course
where we're taught to book early to save
money
is just a difficult thing to do it's an
awkward feeling
but i suspect that the long-term rewards
are actually quite a bit better
rory thanks for joining spectator tv
always a huge pleasure thank you very
much indeed
that's it for this week remember if you
enjoy what we do here at the spectator
you can subscribe to the magazine and to
our online content join today and you'll
pay just one pound a week for unlimited
online and app access in your first year
to subscribe today go to spectator dot
co dot uk forward slash tv offer
and don't forget to subscribe to the
spectator's youtube channel just click
the subscribe button at the bottom of
this video and tap the bell icon to make
sure you never miss an episode
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]
you